[Music]
letterpress printing is a centuries-old
method that's making a comeback
the printing press makes an impression
in the paper with raised type as it
applies the ink
the printer first sketches out some
design ideas
then he detours into digital technology
finalizing the colors in composition and
choosing the font in traditional metal
type now it's time to set up he locates
the selected font in the type cabinet
each individual character called a sort
is backwards because backwards type
prints forwards he finds the sorts for
the first line of text and lines them up
left to right and upside down and what's
called a composing stick
[Music]
once he completes the type of the line
called a form he clamps it in position
then he takes a metal frame called a
chaise and mounts the form at a specific
position inside the frame filling the
excess space with blocks of wood called
furniture just below the piece of
furniture that's underneath the form he
places a compression device called a
coin and expands it with the key this
locks the form in position he places a
glob on a piece of cardboard and takes
the mixture over to the printing press
he applies it in dots all over the ink
disk
then he pumps on the treadle to run the
rollers back and forth across the disk
this spreads the ink over the disk and
onto the rollers he inserts the chase
containing the form into what's called
the bed of the press now he's ready to
start printing
there's no automation here he manually
places one sheet at a time in the gauge
pens the ink dries quickly because it's
rubber based and because cotton paper
absorbs well this printers technique is
a hybrid of traditional and modern
approaches as he uses computer-generated
graphics he sends the digital file to a
company that makes a polymer printing
plate which he mounts on an aluminum
base that fits in the chase of the press
he switches plates to do the next
graphic in a different color layered
over the first
[Music]
the polymer plates marry the old and new
technology by making it possible to
print computer-generated graphics by
traditional letterpress
[Music]